The broadcast is now starting. All
attendees are in listen-only mode. Hey
everybody, good morning. It's It's Mike
from Order Flows and welcome to today's
presentation. You know, today is
Thursday, June 30th. It's
going to be an interesting day in the
markets. You know, it's not only month
end, but quarter end. And you know, it's
always a busy time of the year whenever
you have a month end and a quarter end.
So,
what I'll be talking about today is
trading with order flow. You know, how
to spot opportunities in the market. And
you know, that's what trading really is.
It's all about opportunities. And if
you know, if if the the thing, you know,
I was watching recently, you know, you
had the Champions League final. And um
you know, it was Liverpool and Real
Madrid.
And I just remember like the
commentators saying, you know, the way
Real Madrid plays is, you know, they
just look for that that moment, that
opportunity to score. You know, and and
that's what happened. If you watch the
game, you know, sorry to you know, you
Liverpool fans, but um
you know, it was just, you know,
normal game going on and then it's just
for that one split moment that
Real Madrid, you know, got the ball and
was able to score. And it's just like
that in trading, right? You see a lot of
um trading going on back and forth, back
and forth. And it's just your normal
flow of uh traders and their activity,
you know, transferring the risk. You
know, that's why the markets exist is to
transfer risk from one party to another.
And it's just that one moment where
things just really
make sense. You see on an order flow
chart that like, yeah, you know, I I get
it now. I I understand what, you know,
all this talk is about order flow. So,
uh let me get my slides here going. The
What's going on?
Trading is about spotting opportunities
in the market and capitalizing them.
Right? And one of the best ways to find
those opportunities is to trade using
the order flow. Okay, so like for
example today in gold, all right, you
had that big run-up this morning. This
is just
this morning at, you know, 7:30, all
right, you had that big run-up. We hit
that high around 8:00 and then we
starting our descent back down.
And if you're just looking at a normal
bar chart like this,
you know, you don't know, are we going
higher or we going lower? You know, but
when you're looking at the order flow,
and I'm going to show you the chart
later, when you see this bar forming
here, you can say, "Yeah, you know what?
We're coming off this high. We're not
going to
make this new high and continue on to
new all-time high or not all-time high,
but new highs
um for the day.
And it's just by understanding the order
flow that the markets are going to make
sense to you. And
order flow trading simply refers to the
trading
based on the orders that are coming into
the market
and trading. All right, people always
talk about, "Oh, you got to look at a
dome. Uh you got to look at the, you
know, the market depth. You got to look
at, you know, a book map, a heat map."
You know, and while those tools are
useful in their own right, you know,
you're not looking at actual
trades that happened in the markets. All
right, you're just looking at people's
intentions. You know, people want to
sell at, you know, a certain price or
buy at a certain price, but if the
market's trading nowhere near there,
okay, what good is that information
going to do
for you right now? All right, you got to
trade
in the present.
So, by keeping an eye on the order flow,
you could get a feel where the market is
going and spot trading opportunities
that you might otherwise have missed.
And, you know, sort of the way I like to
describe it
is, you know,
people when they climb a mountain, all
right, that they've never climbed
before,
doesn't mean they can't climb it, right?
It looks daunting at first, but once
they start getting into it, you know,
start moving, going up, you know, then
they they they sense of you know, you're
not you know, it's better for me to go
this way or better for me to go that
way. And it's the same thing with order
flow. You're going to find ways to
analyze the market that it's just going
to make perfect sense. You know, this is
the route for me to go up this mountain,
so to speak.
Now, today what I'll be talking about
are are sort of three keys about order
flow, how order flow trading can give
you an edge in the markets, right? We
all want an edge in the markets. That's
what everyone says. To be successful,
you need an edge. And I'm going to show
you how order flow can give you that
edge in the markets.
I'm going to talk about the differences
between order flow trading and
traditional trading.
And I'm going to talk about, you know,
why you should care about the order flow
footprint chart. You know, there's big
differences between order flow trading
and traditional trading.
Most people don't realize it. They think
trading is trading. No, there there's
all these
you know, basically, you know,
um
when you're trading off of, you know,
traditional technical analysis,
you're basing your decisions based on
past data,
right? As opposed to current data. And
that matters, right? There's a big
difference in that. But, you know,
before I begin, just you know, some of
you guys might be new to who I am and,
you know, listening to me, you know, why
you should listen to me is, you know,
I have experience trading at a very high
level, right? I've started my career
back in the '90s on the CME trading
floor with the Lind-Waldock, you know,
it's a it's a brokerage firm back in the
in in the US back in the doing that got
sold in the '90s.
But, you know, it was a big powerhouse
firm, and I started on the trading floor
there. And I left the floor to join
their off-the-floor trading desk when
electronic trading started taking off.
Unfortunately, electronic trading in
those days happened after trading hours.
So,
I literally worked the graveyard shift
for many years, right? Because to trade
electronically, you know, those are the
the markets that traded technically
overnight. You know, I'd go go the
office at 10:00 p.m. and leave there at
just after 8:30 after the S&P's open on
the floor.
But it was great experience cuz it got
me exposed to other markets and more
importantly, I was sort of on the on the
cusp
of
electronic trading, right? And now
everything's electronic. After that, I
joined EDF Man, a big English trading
company that's been around for over 250
years
on their macro futures trading desk.
Then um
I joined Commerzbank, the big German
bank. I joined it in Chicago. I was a
licensed Eurex trader there
for several years. And then um you know,
after 9/11, I took some time off,
traveled around the world for about half
a year. Then I I joined Cargill, the big
US trading commodity firm. I
um head up their futures trading desk in
Chicago and I even set up a desk for
them in Singapore when the exchange was
closing down.
After that, I joined JP Morgan in
Singapore. I spent 8 years as vice
president of futures trading. So, you
know, I've been exposed to futures
trading basically since the '90s, right?
So, what I'm talking about is what
helped me in my career
to be successful. Right? I mean, it's
not you know, I I
watched a bunch of videos for a year on
YouTube and you know, opened up a
thousand-dollar account at some discount
brokerage. No, you know, I was trading
at these levels. These are actually
trading jobs. And what you're going to
learn today is, you know, based off of
my years of experience.
And in 2015, I started a company called
orderflows.com, which is a software
company.
And
I created my own software for analyzing
order flow because I was not a
I was not satisfied with what was
available on the market for traders
because I was still trading. I was
trading for myself at this point.
And I know that software can do a lot,
right? Rather than just have a basic
charting
program, you know, I wanted to do
analysis for me rather than just
plotting the data.
And the reason why I about that is
because I do want you to understand that
the charts you're going to see in this
presentation are generated from my
software. Okay? But what I'm talking
about are things that you can use and if
you already have a footprint chart an
order flow chart, you can take the
information and apply it
to your trading right now if you want.
But hopefully by the end you're going to
see how easily and quickly you can apply
order flow analysis to your trading to
make better, more informed trades. And
you know, I'm always I I love the
positive feedback I get from customers,
right? It you know, people say you know,
the software is
helps them see what's really happening
in the market, right? And that's really
what you want to do, right? You want to
be able to see what's happening in the
market as opposed to just having the
data in front of you. But having the
data in front of you is one thing, you
have to know how to analyze it. Now
before I jump in, just a brief
disclaimer,
you know, we're all adults here. We
understand that um you know, trading
does involve risk and only risk capital
should be used for trading. And only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading. Okay? So when
it comes to order flow, you something
you have to shift your mind, right?
Because
you're always be going to be looking for
opportunity. People look at the markets
and you know, especially now, you know,
with Bitcoin down, stocks down,
everyone's talking about oh, there's
there's blood in the streets, you got to
be just buy everything. No, you know,
you really what you want to do is you
want to look for that opportunity
in the markets, all right? So yeah, even
though it's it's crisis mode, you know,
everything's falling off, it's the end
of the world, we're in a recession. No,
you know, markets have been around for
150 years, longer than that actually.
You there's been recessions, there's
been market crashes.
And really what you're looking for is
the opportunity within those. And with
the order flow, it's really taking it a
step um
deeper and you're really looking for
opportunity on the daytime frame. You
know, order flow is best used for
intraday trading.
So,
first I'll talk about is how order flow
can give you an edge in the markets,
right? Order flow trading is a trading
strategy that uses market data to
identify trading opportunities.
So, by understanding how orders are
placed and executed, all right? It's not
just, you know, a trade happened. You
want to know how it happened. Okay? Did
someone Was somebody aggressive
there? You know, when the order was
placed, you know, was the trader being
aggressive or was he being passive? That
matters.
Traders can gain an edge over other
market participants by knowing this
information, and it's all there for
everybody. You don't need level two
data, you know, just the level one data,
your normal data feed will suffice.
Order flow trading requires an
understanding of market microstructure,
but the rewards can be substantial. Now,
don't get scared away when I say, "Oh,
you need to know market microstructure."
No, you just need to understand how the
buying and selling is taking place.
And this is ultra bonds, right?
Yesterday,
if you understood what was happening in
the order flow, you'd know that what's
happening down here is quite bullish.
Right? We're at our low of the day,
that's what this red line is.
Yeah, I like to plot the
day's open, high, low, close, so I know
where we are trading relative to the
high or the low, because if we're at a
low,
it could be a great buying opportunity,
right? Everybody always says, "Buy low,
sell high." Right? So, if we're trading
near the low and I see stuff that's
bullish in this order flow,
then it's going to give me an
opportunity
to catch this move here. It all started
down here
in the order flow, right? Now, this
market sold off, stopped here,
and then
got bullish, and the market had a huge
rally.
You know,
this is intraday trading, 149.24,
all the way up to basically 151.20.
This 24 is up here. That's over a $2,000
move just in, you know, from what, 8:20
to basically 10:20, a 2-hour window.
Now, granted, you know, not every day
you're going to have gigantic moves like
that. Now,
every little edge is going to
give you an opportunity
and it's going to make a big difference,
right? Just having a little tiny edge,
just seeing something that other traders
aren't seeing in the market. All right?
And that's where order flow comes in.
All right? By understanding order flow,
you can be able to anticipate price
movements and make trades accordingly.
All right? Back to our ultra bonds
yesterday. All right? You noticed,
right?
Bullish order flow down here on the
footprint chart, I showed you that.
Market went up, pulled back here. Okay?
Why?
Well,
why did stop there? You know, if you're
watching the order flow, you can see
what's happening here already.
All right? We're starting to come back
down, come back down. And then you're
starting to see bullish signs in the
order flow. Don't worry, I'm going to
explain what, you know, all this means
in a minute, but, you know, I want you
to understand how
it
order flow can give you that edge,
right? Because if you're watching the
order flow, you can see, you know, this
bar is very bullish, this bar is very
bullish. Okay? People are going to say,
for example, this bar here, all right?
Oh, it's got negative delta. Mike's got
You know, cuz all I talk about is delta
is is the net difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
in a bar. So, if delta is positive, you
have
net aggressive buyers. If delta is
negative, you have net aggressive
sellers.
People are going to go, "Oh, you know
what, Mike? It's got negative delta.
There's sellers in here." Yeah, there
are, but it's being absorbed
right here.
And if you know there's absorption in
the market,
basically, someone's stepping up to the
plate willing to buy everything that
people are selling.
Eventually, the selling's going to stop.
As long as that person doing that
absorption is is strong, and it is. All
right? He absorbed everything. He took
all the hits from the sellers
till the sellers had no more to sell to
him and then
the market went up, right? That's what
you're looking for
in the order flow, signs like that.
So,
first thing I'll talk about just really
quick is sort of, you know, what I call
the the building blocks of order flow.
There's delta, imbalances, and and point
of control.
And delta is again, it's the net
difference between aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers in a bar.
You know, people think that, you know,
for every buyer there's a seller. Well,
yeah, there is, but you have
aggressive buyers,
you have aggressive sellers, you have
passive buyers, you have passive
sellers.
And the best way to describe it is, you
know, if you're
want to get a trade done, you're going
to be aggressive, right? You're going to
trade at the market. Now, it doesn't
have to necessarily have to be at the
market, you just be lifting the offer,
right? You're buying the existing the
current offer.
Okay? Or selling into the bid.
That is the aggressive activity. If
you're a passive buyer or a passive
seller, passive buyer works a bid.
Passive seller works an offer. Doesn't
mean they're going to transact, right? I
mean, you could be sitting on a bid and
not get anything.
Right? But if you're an aggressive
buyer,
you want to get done, you're going to
lift the offer. You're going to
basically
pay market price, which is whatever is
currently on offer for.
And so, the net difference between those
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
in a bar is the delta.
And the delta, every bar is going to
have a delta. It's either going to be
positive or negative. There's times
where delta does
come to zero on a bar. Like bar closes
and delta's zero, right? It's just
buyers and sellers are evenly matched.
And
you know, I've done a lot of studies on
that and honestly, it it it there's no
magic secret to it. It's just more of a
coincidence on that it landed on zero
um than anything else. Don't say, "Oh,
delta's it must mean something." Now,
you know, I I I personally I haven't
found anything out of it.
So, generally as markets rise, you're
going to have positive delta, right? You
can see it in here, all these green
numbers on the bottom.
Delta would normally be displayed on the
bottom. Some people like to put them
above or below the bar.
But, I just find it easier on the
bottom. And as a market is selling off,
you got negative delta.
Okay? So, that's delta really quick.
Now, imbalances.
Okay? Imbalances are when there's more
aggressive buying
than selling. That would be a buying
imbalance. A selling imbalance would be
the opposite, more aggressive selling
than aggressive buying in a two-way
auction. And it's going to be, you know,
in a two-way auction. So, say the
market's five bid at six.
If you have a buying imbalance, you
know, you'd have like 100 traded at six
and 10 traded
at five. That would be a buying
imbalance. And the selling imbalance
would be the opposite. 100 sold at five,
only 10 bought at six. And generally as
markets are moving directionally, you're
going to see imbalances.
Okay? And, you know, generally as
markets are moving down, like here,
you're seeing the selling imbalances,
right? You can see these red numbers in
a bar. These are selling imbalances.
Then as the market starts moving up,
it's dominated mostly by buying
imbalances. Right? Easy stuff, right?
There's nothing complicated about it.
You don't have to do any fancy math. Um,
you know, you don't have to put up use
indicators that you don't have no idea.
Oh, you use the
you know, people use these indicators,
they have no idea the calculations that
go into it.
Okay? Why you using it? Well, I don't
know, I saw somebody else use it. Why
don't you just trade, right? Read what's
happening in the market, right? Okay,
yeah, I can see that I have aggressive
buyers
in the two-way auction. What does that
mean? Well, it means you have strong
buying as opposed to, you know, buying
and selling that's mixed, right? Bars
here, you can see as we're going
sideways, you're seeing some bars with
both buying and selling imbalances,
right? It's a sideways market in that
point, you know, people are are haven't
really made up their mind. The market's
just going sideways.
Now,
points of control,
okay, points of control are the price
level in a bar with the most volume. And
it's at a price level, right? It's not
in the two-way auction, right? So, which
is a bit different than the imbalances.
So, imbalances occur in a two-way
auction.
Point of control
is the price level in the bar that has
the most volume. So, what was traded on
the bid at that price level and what was
traded on the offer in the price level.
And where it gets interesting is because
you know, every bar has a point of
control. Every bar has a point that has
the most volume, a a price level with
the most volume. And often times
you see them acting as support when a
market is moving up, right? Here.
You can see we got a point of control.
The next bar, where did it come back?
Where did it trade to? What's below this
bar? The previous bar's point of
control. What about this bar?
Below this bar's previous bar's point of
control.
This bar is one tick above the point of
Here, we're just two ticks above, two
ticks above, and then we get three point
of controls
all at the same level.
All right? So, you can see how point of
control on a move up is acting as
support. Just as on a move down here,
it's
acting roughly as resis- resistance,
right? It comes back within a tick here.
Comes back here. All right? Right to the
tick.
Um these two are the same level. We're
just, you know, a tick or two below this
point of control, and then we start
going sideways in here.
Okay? So, you know, that's that's a
rough way to use point of control. I'm
going to show you some other ways as we
dig deeper.
Um so, differences between trading order
flow
and traditional trading. Now, technical
analysis, right? I I said
focuses on chart patterns and price
trends in order to identify trading
opportunities. Now, in contrast
order flow analysis looks at the flow of
orders that are coming into the market
and actually trading in order to engage
the market sentiment. How do you engage
market sentiment? By
seeing where
the aggression is happening, right? Is
Is it happening as the market is moving
up? Is it buying aggression? Yeah,
that's what you like to see.
As the market is moving down
is there, you know, selling imbalances?
Is points of controls moving down? Are,
you know, are the deltas negative?
You'll be looking at things like that.
So, as a result
technical analysis is more concerned
with historical data, while order flow
analysis is focuses on the real-time
data, right? You got to be trading in
the present, not the past, right? We can
all look at a chart
and say, "Oh, yeah, you know, this is a
great buying opportunity, it's a great
selling opportunity." But, when you're
trading, when you're in the heat of the
moment and you got to click the buy or
sell button
right? You want to be You're basing your
decisions off of how is the market
acting right now, not how it acted 2
weeks ago.
What's happening right now?
So, by understanding the order flow of
real trades, traders get a better sense
of current underlying lying supply and
demand in the market.
And really, you know, that's what you're
doing. That's the process as a trader.
Right? You you you
ask yourself a question, what's
happening in the market? And you start
to think, then you then oh, yeah, I got
it. Now, I know what to do. Okay?
Now, a limitation of technical analysis
is that it's based on historical data
which may or may not be indicative of
future price movements, right? Market
conditions change rapidly. What worked
in the past may work in the future.
And you know
there's a saying, you know, in in the
trading world, you know, at least we had
it at a Morgan
you know, people would talk about a move
that happened in the past be like, "Oh,
yeah, you know,
man lands on moon. That's ancient
history. What's happening right now?
Right? You want to know what's happening
right now so you can capitalize on it.
Right? Things that happened in the past,
yeah, okay, it's it's good to know,
but how's that going to help me right
now? Oh, yeah, you know,
I I picked the low of the S&P in in 2008
that you know, whatever, 600. Okay,
great. It's 10 years later, so what?
What does that mean? How's that going to
help me right now? What's going on right
now?
So, this limitation, right? The relying
on historical data means that
does
not take into account new information
that could impact
future price movements, right? Yeah, you
know, people draw their their charts,
you know, draw on their charts, rather,
draw their trend lines, draw this, draw
that, you know, their their squiggly
lines, but
what happens when
new information comes to the market,
right? That's when looking at the order
flow takes into account that new
information.
Right? So, if market-moving news comes
out,
this news will not be reflected in past
data.
Okay, you have to analyze it, right?
Because, you know, honestly,
if
you look at past history, you know, if
you look at a chart up to a
a certain time period, right? When it
before a number came out, after that
number came out, everything to the left
of that
when the number came out doesn't matter
anymore.
Right? People are trading based off this
new information that came out, right?
This new CPI came out, right? GDP comes
out, right? After that, everyone's idea
of what's happening in the market is
changing. So, basing your analysis on
you know,
previous information that's useless now,
that doesn't matter anymore, how how's
that going to help you? So, that's why
technical analysis often gives you false
signals in many situations.
So, this is e-minis yesterday, all
right? Why did the market stop here,
right? Market went up, stopped, right?
Then market tried to come back up a
couple times and stopped and obviously,
you know, we're 100 points lower right
now.
If you're looking at the
order flow, you can see you have a big
seller up here.
Right? There's several thousand
contracts on the offer up here.
Basically, it's sitting in the book.
It's trading and you can see how Look at
what happened the first time
it traded up there, right? It's kind of
you know,
people say, "Is this a triple top?" You
know, it's three bars in a row where you
hit the same level. This is a 1-minute
chart. First time you trade up there,
trades a thousand What is that? A
thousand eighty-seven contracts.
Can't get through, comes off a little
bit. Here comes the second charge.
1,624 contracts, still can't get through
it.
Okay? People are getting like kind of
depressed, you know, that they're trying
to break it out to the upside, right? I
remember seeing yesterday on Twitter
everyone saying, "Oh, we're going to
have a face-ripping rally."
All right? Well, we you know, did we?
You know, we went up from 3805
up to 3840.
Then it just stalled, right? Because
there was a big seller up there. There's
big resistance up there.
And now you're seeing strong move into
it, a thousand, sixteen hundred.
Third time, a hundred.
What do you think that means, right?
People have been trying to
break through this level and they can't.
They finally just give up here.
Comes off a little bit.
Starts coming back up.
But as it's coming back up, where's the
volume? It's 17 contracts, 96.
120.
Where's the enthusiasm? It's not there.
When you're coming up here before, you
know, it's trading 600, trading 700.
Couldn't get through, comes off, starts
coming back up and it's just trading,
you know, 1790.
Forget about it. Stick a fork in it.
Right? You could even see
Well, it came up again here, right? And
still came off.
These were the second times it the third
time it came here. Eight contracts, 34
contracts, 47.
What's happening in here? Nothing. Do
you see a strong aggressive buying? No,
not really. You don't see many buying
imbalances, you know, this bar's got
three here. This one's got one.
You know, now you're starting to see as
you're starting to fail on these
attempts back up, what are you seeing?
You're seeing
selling imbalances start to come in.
Selling imbalances start to come in.
When earlier there were no selling
imbalances. So now, all right, you've
coming back up, making another run up
towards the high of the day.
And they these moves they're just
getting weaker and weaker every time
they come up here.
All right, what's the delta telling you?
Well, obviously you got the negative
delta here. Here you got some decent
delta, 400.
Then nothing, 63, 34, then another 300.
Okay, you got 300 delta.
And it's not going higher, but it's a
red candle. So what is telling you,
right? You have that
positive delta, but the bar closes down.
That's actually a negative sign because
what you have now, you still got
absorption happening
up here at these lower
levels. The high of the day is up here,
right? So it's just right off our high
of the day, but now I know I've got
offers in here. People that are looking
for to trap those buyers thinking that
this market is going to keep rallying.
Right? That's why you got the positive
delta, 364. It's because you got passive
sellers in there willing to step up and
and
absorb all the buying pressure in that
market.
All right? And then you see again,
little sideways activity. Again, you
you're seeing some decent Delta 500,
300, 200, but as it's going up, right?
They expect this market to keep going
up. All right, then it gets up here.
Then it's negative Delta. When you're
going up, right? You want to be going up
on stronger Delta. You want the 300, the
200, then the 300, then the 500, not
sort of some nice buying coming in here,
then lesser, then even lesser, then
peaks right here and turns negative.
That's not what you like to see on a
market that you're expecting to go up.
What's point of control is doing? Well,
here you can see they're they're moving
lower. You get these two side by side.
This one obviously pops up a little bit,
and then it just drops back down.
So, technical analysts will be waiting
for a break to sell, right? They'll be
drawing their trend line from here. Oh,
look at
it's holding this nicely.
And, you know, I mean, there's nothing
wrong with drawing a trend line from
here, connecting these dots here,
coming up here, but by the time you sell
here, time to be selling is up here as
it's happening.
All right, you could see what's
happening in the order flow. You'd be
getting short somewhere up here, rather
than down here.
Right?
Technical analysts, you know, they're
always waiting for confirmation. Oh, we
got to break this trend line.
You got to do this, got to do that. And
often times
you're just stuck around waiting for
things that that never happen. And, you
know, I understand the whole concept of
having a trading plan, you know, what
I'm going to do if the market goes up,
market goes down, but you really, you
know,
you need to be trading in the moment,
right? If the market is telling you,
yeah, you know what? We have our high of
the day here. There's big sellers up
here. I see
buyers being absorbed by passive sellers
up in here.
You know, I could be looking to get
short up here, rather than waiting for a
break, you know, somewhere down here
another 5 10 points lower.
Right, where would you rather be getting
short here at 25 or up here at 35?
Right, cuz if you're getting short here
at 25, you know, your stop is still up
here around 40.
So, if you're getting short at 35 with a
stop up at 40, you only got five points
at risk. As opposed to getting short at
25 with a stop up at 40, you're risking
15 points. Right, so that's how order
flow, knowing where these um big trades
happened in the past and that's holding
down the market like you saw yesterday,
that's a great area to hide behind cuz
you know that what traded there was
important. So,
that leads us into the next point, you
know, why you should care about an order
flow footprint chart. Well, if you're
trading without an understanding of
order flow, you're really trading blind.
Now, simply put, an order flow
chart shows you who's winning and losing
the battle at any given moment. Right,
you want to know who's in charge of the
market. A lot of times it's it's back
and forth, you know, things market's
trading back and forth, no real
direction, but there are those times
where
what you see in the market just makes
perfect sense. Right, that that you you
you go, oh yeah, you know what, I I get
it, right? You can see here, right, this
is
What is this? Is the E-minis yesterday,
right? Got this little sell-off here,
then we got this little rally here.
Okay, so as you're coming down, okay,
point of control's moving down, that's
what you like to see, volume moving
lower, right? Point of control, again,
the price level in the bar with the most
volume.
So, if the price level in the bar
it's not just, you know, bar's trading
lower, but you're seeing the volume in
the bar transacting lower and lower.
Now, people say, well, yeah, you know,
obviously if a bar's going down, volume
is going down.
Okay, yeah, but really what you're
seeing is is
in this bar, where is the heaviest
volume appearing appearing towards the
bottom. Then in the next bar, okay, it's
around the same level. But then in the
next bar,
the heaviest volume is lower. Next bar,
heaviest volume is lower. Next bar,
heaviest volume is lower.
Then it gets here. Now you finally got
your first green candle.
Okay? Again, point of control,
the volume
still low.
Okay?
Then it jumps up.
All right? It's a big flip in terms of
volume.
Okay? Then you got the red candle, then
the green candle. It's around the same
level, and then a little bit higher.
Three little bars here.
Down, down, down, but then higher,
higher, higher, higher.
Okay? What's delta doing? Well,
obviously on your move down, it's
negative, right? That you like to see.
Then as it's coming down in here, right?
This is where it gets interesting.
You got your big negative deltas coming
in here. Minus um what is that? 800.
This one's minus 1,200, and this one's
minus 900. Okay.
Market's going down. Strong aggressive
selling. Yes, that's what you expect to
see.
Mark goes still goes down, makes a new
low,
but does it on very small delta, and
it's actually positive. It's 15.
Okay? So, what's that telling you?
Well, yeah, we went lower,
right? Imagine if you don't even see
what happened here on this this move
back up, but you see that strong
selling, strong selling,
very little
aggressive selling,
um net aggressive selling. I don't want
to say there's no aggressive selling,
but it's delta's the difference between
net aggressive buying and net aggressive
selling. So, what you've got aggressive
selling happening in here, but it's
being absorbed by the buyers, right?
That's why you don't have a big strong
negative delta of minus 1,000. It's just
small. It's positive 15, which is kind
of neutral.
Especially if you're having bars with
minus a thou- minus 800, minus 900,
minus 1,000, then you get yeah, 15. So,
the buyers are are coming in. People are
absorbing
the selling that's happening there.
Right? And then you can just see it it
flipped right here, right? You you still
have negative delta, it's a green
candle, right? It's the sign of
absorption. Because you have passive
buyers here
on the bid side that are absorbing all
that aggressive selling. Not only that,
but then in this bar
you got buying aggressive buying
towards the end of the bar. This is a
minute base chart, so early in the bar
it's a negative strong negative delta.
But second half of the bar it's positive
delta
in a sense, right? You got the
aggressive buying going on in here.
Right? Because this bar, even though the
delta's minus 405,
at one point it was minus 800, so it
actually
it gained back 400
in the delta.
Right? Because it was minus 800
something, and it got to just minus 400.
So, it went from minus 800 to minus 400,
so it's actually
a small gain, you know, it's it's hard
to see that unless you're looking at the
max and min delta. So, people say,
"Well, it's still got a big negative
delta." Well, yeah,
it's negative, but it wasn't as negative
as it was earlier in the bar.
Then positive delta, positive deltas,
positive deltas start coming in.
Okay? So, you can take that, right? You
can have a sense of where the market is
going. Do you think it's going to go up
or it's going to go down? Right? You
always want to be asking yourself
what can happen next based off of what
just happened.
This is euro currency. This is this
morning.
Again, we sort of go in sideways, then
we dip down here, and then we bounce up.
Right? We we just come in,
push lower,
then what happens? All right, nice big
rally up. And again, watch the point of
controls. Are they moving up or are they
moving down? This is a simple way to
determine a trend. It doesn't take like
many bars.
If you're starting to see, you know,
three or four bars where points of
controls are moving up,
yeah, you could say this market's moving
up. Just as here, right? Okay, yeah, the
market's moving down. Then it gets to
this
point right here
where you have
selling imbalance, you got this buying
imbalance.
You
Basically, what you're happening here,
right? Trap traders. People love to talk
about trap traders, but they never
explain it, right? They never say,
you know, they'll just pick a point on a
chart sometimes and just looks arbitrary
and, you know, if you're looking at a
bar chart, they say, "Well, yeah, you
got trap traders there."
Well, here you can really see trap
traders, right? People selling down in
here, right? Selling 123, turned it off
or sold 151. So, that's about close to
300 contracts that traded here.
Aggressive selling mixed with
passive selling.
Yet, we're trading 10 ticks higher.
What do you think that means, right? You
had big seller
right here.
Market's not going lower.
Okay? Well, he's trapped.
And you can see how the market reacted
to it.
All right? Obviously, you can see the
volume start moving higher as well in
each bar.
So, that's where using a footprint chart
is going to help you.
Now,
you can actually add
more forms of order flow analysis
to your chart.
Right? And, you know, I talk about the
order flow trader software that I
developed, and it gives me additional
insights into the market. Like,
now I can see, you know, this bar, I've
got
a lot of aggressive buying taking place
here. This bar, 1 2 3
imbalances, right? It's telling me that
I have
imbalances that are just spread out in
the bar.
So, imagine, right? I see the market
come down into the a swing low, and I
see multiple buying imbalances. What do
you think that means? Well, it means
that we hit a swing low.
Buyers are attracted come in. Not just
buyers, but aggressive buyers are
attracted come into the market.
And the market starts moving up, right?
Two bars later, more aggressive buying,
right? Three imbalances here. Another
three imbalances here. Now, digging a
little bit deeper,
you know, if anybody's ever spent any
time with
volume profile market profile, you
understand what the value areas are.
And you can actually plot them on a bar
as well.
So, not only do you see the points of
control, which is the volume,
but now you can see the value areas in a
bar. Are those value areas migrating
higher?
Well, we know that off of, you know,
based off
profile analysis, that
when you see value areas moving higher,
you know, the market is trending up.
Just as if you see value areas move
lower, you know, the market's trending
down. And by looking at it on a
bar-by-bar basis, it's going to give you
an insight
faster insight into changes in the
market.
All right? You can see here, right? This
market, it just flipped on you, right?
It looked like it was going lower.
Then we see the value areas just within
two, three bars
are much higher. That That That's your
sign.
All right? You want to be getting
um positioning yourself long. You know,
there's a lot of times where it's just
mixed, right? It's just value areas are
overlapping like here or here.
But when it just comes down, dips down,
value area low prints down there, then
I say the value area prints here at a
low, and then it comes in higher,
higher, higher, higher. Well, yeah, you
know that
this market is is really getting ready
to to make a move.
Now, this morning, this was this morning
in the E-minis.
Trapped traders again down here, right?
And people say, you know, how can you
tell? Well, I got aggressive selling,
you know, at the low of the bar and the
bar is trading higher. Like that's easy
sign of trapped traders.
All right? And it's just one of those
things that you see that happen. Okay,
yeah, you know, I could just get long. I
could take a nice quick scalp up here.
Now, there's other things
that the order flow trader software can
do for you.
Right? It could show you strong
aggressive selling taking place. That's
this red area. That's this red area.
This is red area. Just as if there's
strong aggressive buying taking place.
That's this green area. This green area.
Okay? So, there's ways of analyzing the
order flow that you just can't see on a
normal
bar chart, right? Here's your normal
gold chart. This is this morning, right?
It's the the chart I showed you at the
very beginning.
That big run up
came off a little bit, made that new
high,
and fell over.
Right? This is a move, you know, from
the 20s down into the teens. I don't
know where we're trading at.
Right now, I think we're even I think
right now we're trading somewhere
around, you know, below 10. I think
we're around 08
or something like that.
But
wouldn't you like to know
if you're looking at this chart when
it's trading up in here
that there's something bearish in the
order flow? Well, yeah, you know, that's
why you use an order flow chart. So,
this is your normal footprint chart that
most traders will use, right? And it'll
give you your
buying and selling imbalances. It'll
give you your point of control. It'll
give you your delta.
And you know, up here you could see,
yeah, you got a divergence, right? You
got a new high. You got negative delta.
That's what a divergence is.
Um
my order flow is trader software will
actually print
what I call the order flow ratios, which
will tell you if it's bullish or
bearish. And this is bearish order flow,
right? I know that cuz it the blue
number up here it tells me it's bearish.
If it was a black number, it would just
be normal order flow.
So, it's a red candle with bearish order
flow on the top at the high of the day.
Got a divergence.
So, obviously got negative delta. All
right. What do you think this market's
going to be doing? It's going to be
looking to start moving down. It's not
going to keep going up.
And there's even other little tools that
we've developed that will show you
things
like
um you know, it'll draw down arrows if
it's bearish or up arrows if it's
bullish.
Now, again, looking at the value areas,
right?
This is a very bearish value area.
That's why we draw it red color.
All right. Tell you just to highlight to
you
you know, hey, you know what? This order
flow is very bearish up here at the high
of the day. And you're up here at the
high of the day
and you see this bearish order flow come
in, you don't need to wait
until it starts selling off. All right.
The area to be getting short is right
here.
Market does sell off, comes right back
up to that area where you'd gotten short
anyway.
All right. Rather than you know, if you
draw your trend line, you draw it up
here. You know, people say, "Oh, look at
this nice beautiful trend line here."
Right? And it is. It's a nice trend
line, right? You draw it from
this point to this point to this point
and it breaks here.
Okay. Comes back up. Maybe, you know,
the trend line was still going up here.
You're getting short somewhere in here,
1820. Again, where would you rather get
short? 18 18 or 18 24?
Right? What do you I'd much rather get
short up here at at 24 than at 18.
Right? You're just giving up all that
stuff by waiting for confirmation. When
you got your confirmation already that
is bearish up in here
at the high.
All right. You're not waiting for the
market to fall apart to to pieces. You
You're getting short right now based off
of what you're seeing in the footprint
right here at this high.
Bunch of selling imbalances. You got a
bearish value area.
Obviously you the negative delta, you
got the negative order flow, you got
everything going for you. You got like
five things in the order flow going for
it. Market sells off a little bit, comes
back up, more bearish information in the
order flow, that's why there's that. You
can just see the deltas are all negative
here.
And again, it's just those are those
things that just stand out. Now, another
thing I want to talk about is
the delta footprints. All right. The
delta footprint is basically a footprint
based on the delta
at a price
in the bar. It's a horizontal, it's not
in the two-way auction. Whereas, you
know, the the footprints I was showing
you before take into account all the
volume that trades on the bid and the
offer. The delta footprint takes it a
step further. It looks at just the
delta at price. So, for example,
this bar here, it's got two, right? It's
got a positive two. So, it's telling you
there was
two more aggressive buying than selling
at this price level.
Now, where this gets useful
is you're going to see some bars
like this, all negative delta, a red
bar. So, it's just telling you this bar
opened up and it was just
net aggressive selling at each price
level.
Right? Cuz often times what you're going
to see in a bar is you're going to see
volume go back and forth, right? Volume
traded on the bid, volume traded on the
offer. Then you're going to get these
bars where it's just all aggressive
buying at each price level.
Positive delta, positive delta, positive
delta. Right? What do you think this
market is going to do? It's going to
give you some nice scalping
opportunities
in the market, right?
Euro currency,
right? Look at this. Market sort of dips
down here.
Aggressive buying comes in, all
aggressive buying in this bar. Now, this
bar had mostly aggressive buying, it's
got two price levels with
some aggressive selling.
But these bars like this, right?
It is telling you, hey, you know what?
Aggressive buyers are coming in, not
just coming in, but coming in with
strength.
Okay, this is
Y M is a 100 tick chart. I mean, most of
the charts I show you are are time-based
charts. I use time-based. I also look at
tick-based and volume-based. Um you
could use order flow on
basically any type of chart. I renko
chart, you can't because you need to use
um historical data if you want to see
the the past order flow.
It's just one of the limitations of a
renko chart. I mean, there's other
limitations as far as back testing, etc.
But, you know, just
Heikin Ashi charts, you could use order
flow on.
But, you know, if one thing if there was
one thing you just looked at on a order
flow chart,
and you just look at the delta
footprint, just look for these bars
where it's just all aggressive buying or
all aggressive selling.
Right? Just spend a day looking at them,
right? And then see how, you know, that
can give you some great trading
opportunities.
Cuz at the end of the day, right?
Everybody's looking at the same chart,
but not everybody's looking at the same
information.
So, imagine if you had
another level of information
that nobody else is looking at. I don't
say nobody else mean, but majority,
overwhelming majority of other traders
is not paying attention to.
All right? What do you think? That's
where you're going to get your edge.
It's from the information, right? That's
why you know, people go to jail over
information, right? Insider trading.
Insider trading is is illegal. This is
not insider trading. It's taking the
information that's available to
everybody
and putting it into a format that's easy
to read and analyze and make trading
decisions from.
So, remember here, the more intricate
and complex a trading methodology, the
more likely psychological obstacles are
going to develop and hinder your
trading. All right, you want to not be
confused when it comes to trade Oh,
should I buy or should I sell? Oh, yeah,
you know what? I I I see this bar it's
all aggressive buying.
Should I sell? Well, why why the heck
would you sell? You should be in buying
mode.
All right, you should be looking to get
long, not thinking well, well, maybe I
should be looking to get short. No, why
would you? It's all aggressive buying
that just happened.
All right?
Again, the more complex things are, you
become confused about the data and you
find yourself unable to make decisions.
You're going to
realize you're going to think I just
better do nothing. All right, and you're
going to cost yourself trades. You're
going to cost yourself You know, you
might as well not be trading. You know,
that inaction may seem like the most
rational option. Are you going to do
nothing? Ah, you're not going to give it
some time, let it develop. No, all
right?
That's the problem with things that are
too complex. You don't understand them.
Simple and obvious is always better than
complex and convoluted. Order flow is a
simple and obvious way. Trading
successfully often requires taking
calculated risks and making quick
decisions. You know, when on the trading
floor,
you know, guys didn't have
you know, the back in the '90s and even
in the early 2000s, all right, if guys
wanted to look at a chart, they had to
step out of the pit. All right, they had
to go to the side wall and stand in line
to use a CQ G machine.
All right, and pull up a chart. All
right, then they'd print it out then
they could draw the you know, mark it up
however they they wanted to back in the
pit. But, you know, it's not like people
were on a phone and and pulling up
TradingView on on their iPhone and
you know, finding these levels. No, you
know,
they're not using these indicators there
on the floor, right? They're they're
reading the order flow, the the flow of
orders coming into the market and how
the market is accepting or rejecting
those price levels.
So, over the last 45 minutes or so,
hopefully you'll agree it's been time
well spent, So, I I hope you guys are
coming away with some good information.
Unfortunately, I can't cover everything
in a quick training session like this,
all right? But, I got a special offer so
you can get the information that you
need, know what to look for in the order
flow,
and get going, all right? So,
the offer that I got for you involves
the Order Flows Trader software. Right
now, it runs on NinjaTrader 8. So, if
you're not using NinjaTrader, you use a
footprint on
you know, other platforms, but really,
you know, if you're trading futures,
at least you can download the free
version of NinjaTrader. My software will
run on it. You will need, you know, data
for it. You will need to to subscribe to
a data feed, but I do know that there
are I do have customers that have my
software on the free version of
NinjaTrader. They just pay for the data
feed, and then, you know, they trade
over some other front end, right?
Provided by the broker or, you know,
another charting platform.
And basically, what Order Flows Trader
is, it's like plugging a computer to my
brain, right? My
my vast knowledge of order flow
analysis, so to speak, I I put it into a
program so you can see what
institutional traders are doing in the
market. I do realize that having order
flow software is one thing. You still
got to know how to use it. So, I don't
just give you software and say, "Hey,
thanks, you know, for for buying it. You
know, I'll see you on the other side."
No, you know, I provide a lot of further
education, cuz that's really what you
want, right? You don't want just
software and not know how to use it. I
buy software all the time, not just
trading software, but all other types of
software, and I get frustrated because I
can't
figure out how to use it because a lot
of times the documentation sucks, and
and you can't um get any help and and
just getting it set up the way, you
know, you you see something
online like, "Oh, this software is going
to change your life. You can do this,
this, this." And then, you put it on,
and you you can't figure out how to use
it.
Like these graphic softwares, you know,
I'm not the most I'm not computer
illiterate, but trying to get me to use
things like Photoshop
very difficult.
Um and it shouldn't be that way. Also
with trading software.
Because at the end of the day, right,
you got to know what to look for in the
order flow. So I'm going to give you
access
to the order flow trading course. And I
sell this on my website 297. I sell it
every day.
People
will, you know, have another software,
but they need the education on know how
to use it. I'm going to give you this
for free when you get my software. But
also give you access to my inner circle
video series.
And you know, what that consists of,
there's 56 videos on there of advanced
order flow
um tips and analysis, you know,
different ways to look at the market
that you that you probably never thought
of before. So the software, normally I
sell it for 899.
The training
the order flows trading course 297, the
inner circle
video series is just about $500. So it's
almost $1,600.
It's $1,700.
Now, I do realize that that's a lot of
money to invest for some people, okay?
And but again, I got a special offer,
you're not going to pay that.
And you know, when you make an
investment in in software like that, all
right, you want some access to
me and you know, questions you may have.
So what I do every week
for the last 3 years
you know, I do take time off for
holidays, you know, or you
know, sometimes an emergency comes up.
But actually, you know, this side says
157. There's actually over 170 episodes.
It's one thing to learn from books and
videos, you know, what you want is some,
you know, real-time interaction. And so
I do a live training session every
Tuesday night
where you can ask your questions, any
question on trading or the software, you
know, like I'm having a
you know, installing the software or
Mike, you know, this can you help me
out? Or Mike, you know, I saw this in
the market, what do you think of it? You
know, people send me their charts, I go
over it.
All right? And I'm there every week, you
know, it's like except for like
Christmas and 4th of July, I'm not
having one um
on Tuesday, but
you know, I'm there. I'm there it's a
place where you know you can find me for
sure. Tuesday nights, 7:00 to 8:00 p.m.
Central Time. And it's free to all
users, right? You can see here, I
haven't posted last the other days,
but it's 170 as of June 21st,
2020.
It's actually 171 as of
the 28th, but I just haven't had a
chance to put it up yet. But you're
going to get access to those replays if
in case you miss it.
And some people charge you extra to
answer your questions and have
interaction like this. Oh yeah, you buy
my software then I'll you know, sell you
on a trading room.
For what? That should be included with
it, right? Some people charge a couple
hundred bucks for that.
Now, what I discuss today is just some
of the forms of analysis that I talk
about weekly in those weekly sessions
cuz I do
go over interesting things in the order
flow that
you might have find useful you know, in
your analysis.
So, to get started, all you got to do is
go to orderflows.com/
oft5.html.
Oft5, Order Flows Trader 5.html.
Very simple.
Scroll down page. It's going to take you
to the there's some videos and some more
instruction about the software, but to
get started,
just click this button.
All right? And it's only $749,
right? It's not $1,800, $1,700. It's
only a one-time payment of 749.
And it's processed through PayPal.
All right? Everybody's got a PayPal
account. Everyone should be familiar
with what PayPal is.
You just go through there.
Now, you know, bear in mind it does take
some time to generate your usernames,
your licenses, cuz again, I'm giving you
access to several courses. So, just give
it, you know,
a little bit of time. Usually it gets
out to you pretty quick within an hour
or so, but you know, I do say give it a
couple hours maximum. And it goes to
your
email that was used in PayPal when you
made the payment, right? Sometimes
people
have PayPal accounts they don't realize
that their email has changed. So, you
know, if your email's changed,
please check your previous email.
And it's just a one-time payment of
$7.49,
right? And you get all that you get all
that stuff.
And as a special bonus
for you guys from investors,
Expo, you know, you get this
order flow playbook, right? It's $297.
Normally I sell it, again, actually I
don't really sell it anymore cuz it's
it's I I do trainings and I I offer them
to people, then I sort of put them on
the back burner, right? I I I
lock them back up in the vault.
And, you know, maybe once a year, twice
a year, I'll I'll make it available
again for a limited time, right?
Because, you know, I want to teach you
how to read the order flow,
but same time, you know,
I want you to apply it to the trading.
So, get started now. Go to
orderflows.com/oft5.html.
There's no monthly recurring charges you
have to pay me. I hate that software
that you got to keep paying for the rest
of your life. Cancel your credit card,
they just start taking the money out of
your bank. No.
It's just a one-time payment. Now,
again, you do have to pay your data
fees, right? That is a monthly charge.
If you you know, you need data to run
any sort of If you're trading, you need
data. That's a given.
And your NinjaTrader fees, whatever
those are, if you're using NinjaTrader,
right? If you have a paid version, okay,
great. Some people would like to lease
the version, um but again, you could run
on the free version of NinjaTrader as
well. You still need a data feed,
though.
So, what you're going to get is you're
going to get the Order Flows Trader 5.0,
which is our current version,
valued at 899. You're going to get
access to the Order Flow Trading Course,
which is 297,
the Inner Circle video series, which is
497,
the Order Flow Live weekly
group training access to
You know, I don't want to put a price on
that, but I know people charge several
hundred dollars a month for that.
You get
access to that for as long as you have
the the software. All right? And there
are people that attend those
that have been using my software for as
longer than I've actually been doing the
training the the weekly group training.
And you get to access to the Order Flow
Playbook. And in that playbook, you're
going to learn I think it's 10, maybe 11
great order flow trade setups that you
can take advantage of.
And again, the reason why I provide all,
you know, trading course, the Inner
Circle video series,
the playbook, and even the weekly group
training cuz I want you to understand
what to look for in the order flow.
All right? A lot of people buy a
footprint chart,
buy order flow software, and don't know
what to look for.
You're not going to sit in front of the
screen and just figure it out overnight.
Maybe
over time you could figure it out, but
why spend all that time? Why not just
jump to the front of the queue by
learning what to look for
rather than trying to figure it out all
on your own. And it's just a one-time
payment of 749.
All right? So, just get started. Go to
orderflows.com/oft.
I'll put it in the chat here for you.
Okay?
Now, again, you I didn't mention it at
the beginning, but, you know, for some
of you guys that want to learn more
about order flow for
I do have I did write a book on trading
order flow.
Right? You're not going to get the hard
copy. It's just a digital download.
Just go to orderflows.com/book.html.
Enter your name and email address. Click
submit, and it'll take you to a page
where you can download the book. Okay?
So, just go to orderflows.com/book.html.
You got to put the .html
on there
to get the book.
All right? So, again,
you got to get started.
Right? Go to orderflows.com/oft5.html.
And in the end, right? We regret the
chances we didn't take. You know, just
last night, I was talking to my
sister-in-law and
and her sister,
you know, she's already pushing 50.
She's got no kids, and now she's
regretting it.
Right? Like, "Oh, you know what? Maybe I
should have had kids." You know, but
she's at the point now where it's too
late. And you know, I see that a lot
with with people wanting to get into
trading. "Yeah, I want to trade. I want
to learn how to trade." But then they
never do anything.
Okay? They
email me message, you know,
give them a list of books to read.
And then a year later, I hear back from
them, "Oh, yeah, I'm still interested."
Did you read those books? No.
You got to get started at some point.
Right? So, go to orderflows.com/oft5.
Um
I'm going to take a couple questions
here.
What time frame are you talking now?
Again, you know,
when you're looking at
order flow,
you
it's really meant for per day trading.
Okay? It's meant for people that are
going to
be trading in and out during the day,
not holding the position. Not Not It's
not really meant for swing trading.
There are people that do, um but their
knowledge of order flow is a bit more
advanced, right? They They understand a
lot of things and looking for very
specific nuances. But I talk about that
in in the weekly sessions as well
sometimes. Um
you know, things on on a bit longer time
frames.
Uh yeah, there'll be a replay.
And um last question here, how much is
the data fee on NinjaTrader?
Well, okay, what you can do
is
you can get data from different sources,
right? You can get it from the broker or
you can pay, you know, a third party
like IQ feed or
Kinetic.
But the real-time data feeds are
keep going up.
And if you were to get say a real-time
data fee feed for just CME,
you know, just like all their contracts,
it's like $100 or something.
But what people do
is they open a trading account at
NinjaTrader
and just fund it with,
you know, 250 bucks, 300 bucks, cuz, you
know, you could trade these micro
contracts. The the margins are only $50.
So, you could basically keep, you know,
a minimum amount in your trading account
and subscribe to the data feed through
them.
And you're going to be paying a very low
fee, right? Your
fee is only going to be like, I think I
I think I pay around $60 a month for
CME,
CBOT, NYMEX, Eurex level one and level
two.
I do have level two because I do look
at, you know, the depth of the market
and the order book when I'm trading,
but, you know, that's how people
are able to get a lower
um
data fee, right? Cuz still honestly, $60
a month for a real-time data is
is
very inexpensive.
So,
and it's okay, it's one thing to again
have a data feed,
right? But you also got to be it's got
to be a trading feed as well cuz it's
not just one way,
right? Where it's just coming from the
exchange to you.
All right, if you're trading, needs to
be two-way. So,
needs to plot on your chart and you be
able to send the
the order through that as well.
So, again, you I hope that answers, you
know, everybody's questions there. So,
again, to get started, just go to
orderflows.com/oft5
.html.
And
you know, again, you know, at some
point, right? If you want to be a
trader, you got to start trading and it
you know, it's a great way to analyze
the markets, you know, order flow really
is gets you as close to the markets as
as possible,
right? It's basically you're seeing and
understanding the buying and selling
that's going on.
Rob asks, "Does level two help you?
It's moving so fast." You know,
when I look at level two, I don't
yeah, it does move super fast. I mean,
it's especially nowadays, you know,
maybe
10 years ago it was it was much slower
and you could just sort of, you know,
drink your coffee as you watch it level
two, but now it's forget about it. It's
it jumps all over the place. I use level
two cuz I do look at things like um
the market depth map, right? NinjaTrader
has that on their paid version.
Just get an idea, you know, if there's
big resting orders someplace.
Okay? Cuz you know, that that does
matter, right? Cuz say you're in a trade
and you have a target level,
but if you're looking at
the resting liquidity in the order book
and there's, you know, say you're long
from 27 and you got a target at 45, say,
but at 37, 38, 39 you see big heavy
orders really stacked. I mean, like
thousands of contracts in the E-minis or
something. Okay, maybe 45's not
realistic, all right? And you know, as
it gets closer then you could have start
reassessing. But that's how I I use
level two.
I do have thinkorswim. Mauricio asked, I
have thinkorswim. I don't have Ninja
account. What do you recommend to do?
Um
Well, like I just sort of explained it
there. I mean, if you want
to use the software, just
you could run it on the free version of
NinjaTrader. You will need obviously a
data feed for it and you could execute
over over TOS, which is I I have people
that do that.
Um and again, you can get the data feed
through NinjaTrader brokerage.
They only sign up for NinjaTrader give
you like free 2 weeks anyway of data.
But again, you know, rather than paying
for this real-time cuz the data feed
from them is the CQG continuum feed,
which is very reliable. Um
you know, I got it running almost 24 24
hours a day, 6 days a week
on my system.
So anyway, guys,
I'll I'll leave it there. You know, I've
been on gone over an hour, so I don't
want to keep you guys on too long. It's
uh
end of the month, so we'll see what
happens going into cash close. So,
thanks everyone for taking that time out
of your day. I appreciate it and I hope
to see you guys on the inside. Thank
you. Bye-bye.